[Music]
i mean i think we need to
to be able to criticize some of the you
know the ideas that have come up even
thus far in this conversation uh
ideas about race and gender and i think
these are
there's a kind of moral panic and you
know even hysteria
brewing here which i think is socially
very damaging and politically very
dangerous
and i think it's you know it's the kind
of thing that
if left to do its mad work
unchecked can produce its own spectrum
of you know very damaging effects but
could also produce a a very dangerous
counter reaction right
i largely think of don you know the
the presidency of donald trump at least
in part
as a reaction to what has been happening
on the left
and the influence of the far left on
even very mainstream
uh institutions on you know on on
academia and
on on mainstream journalism and
the the distrust of institutions the
almost ubiquitous uh distrust
institutions now
is to a significant degree a measure of
what the left has done
to these institutions and i consider
myself you know
very much a liberal on you know almost
every point but
the distinction between you know real
liberalism
and what has happened on the far left
has
become increasingly excruciating
the counter-reaction to all of this is
is something that i worry a lot about
and yeah as you probably know i'm
i consider myself as
committed a critic of donald trump as as
really anyone on earth
there's almost nothing to say uh
uh critical of the man that is that
proves an exaggeration
but you know that said so much of the
left's
criticism of him also manages to be in
bad faith
right so for instance while i i do not
doubt that he's a racist
many of the allegations against him
uh alleging his racism are obviously
absurd
the left is so badly calibrated in its
attacks against the right
you know finding nazis everywhere even
where they can't possibly exist
that it's um it's it's so unhelpful
that i think it it energizes it it's
it's counter response
if we happen to live in a universe where
you know to
my horror we wind up with four more
years of of donald trump
which i you know i consider you know
something like an existential threat to
at least to our democracy
i will largely blame the far left for
that
right and it's dishonesty and it's panic
and it's
absolutely bonkers calls to you know
abolish the police right in the united
states right even in the highest crime
parts of our cities right it's just it's
completely nuts and it's exactly the
thought
kind of thing that could get trump
reelected again he may be too far gone
given his inept response to the coveted
pandemic but
if anything is going to get him
re-elected it will be that kind of
craziness and again so to my eye the
left seems to be doing everything
it can to get trump reelected rather
than doing
the sane and prudent things to that it
could do to
to block his his chances